notre ambition est claire gagner la
bataille du climat et ensemble et en
responsabilité et même avec le PPE nous
avions fixé le cap des 2019 celui de la
loi climat notre boussole pour être le
premier continent neutre en émission
carbone nous avons le devoir d'agir
toujours ensemble et en responsabilité
pour tous ceux qui en Europe et dans le
monde subissent les conséquences des
chaleurs extrêmes des sécheresses des
inondations de la montée des eaux nous
ne gagnerons Monsieur le Commissaire que
si nous agissons dans un cadre
multilatéral et en étant cohérent et nos
politiques extérieures doivent être en
ligne avec le Green Deal et notre
politique commerciale doit-elle aussi
davantage ce verdir poussé par la France
l'accord de Paris devient une clause
essentielle de nos futurs accords de
commerce mais il nous faut aller plus
loin ce doit être le cas pour tous les
accords de commerce avec des chapitres
développement durable qui intègrent des
sanctions en cas de non respect des
engagements le climat ne doit pas être
non plus la variable d'ajustement de nos
accords de commerce et l'Union
européenne doit continuer à agir aussi
avec l'OMC pour réellement obtenir nos
objectifs je vous remercie